THAT HE CAN REMEMBER AND MAYBE
IN THE HISTORY.
I SAID WHAT A STATEMENT.
>> YOU SAID THAT THE MIDDLE EAST
WOULD BE BETTER OFF WITH GADHAFI
AND SADDAM HUSSEIN IN POWER.
>> I DIDN'T SAY ASSAD.
WE HAVE NOT GAINED ANYTHING WITH
GADHAFI.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED.
LOOK AT LIBYA.
LOOK AT IRAQ.
IRAQ USED TO BE NO TERRORISTS.
HE WOULD KILL THE TERRORISTS
IMMEDIATELY.
NOW IT'S THE HARVARD OF
TERRORISM.
IRAQ.
IF YOU LOOK AT IRAQ FROM YEARS
AGO, I'M NOT SAYING HE WAS A
NICE GUY.
HE WAS A HORRIBLE GUY BUT IT'S
BETTER THAN IT IS NOW.
RIGHT NOW IRAQ IS A TRAINING
GROUND FOR TERRORISTS.
RIGHT NOW LIBYA NOBODY EVERYBODY
KNOWS LIBYA.
FRANKLY THERE IS NO IRAQ AND
LIBYA.
IT'S BROKEN UP.
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> THE WORLD WOULD BE BETTER OFF
WITH SADDAM HUSSEIN AND GEOADHA
IN POWER.
>> 100%.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THEIR HEADS
CHOPPED OFF.
THEY'RE BEING DROWN.
RIGHT NOW IT'S FAR WORSE THAN
EVER UNDER SADDAM HUSSEIN OR
GADHAFI.
I MEAN, LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
LIBYA IS A CATS TEE --
CATASTROPHE.
LIBYA IS A DISASTER.
IRAQ IS A DISASTER.
SYRIA IS A DISASTER.
THE WHOLE MIDDLE EAST.
IT ALL BLEW UP AROUND HILLARY
CLINTON AND AROUND OBAMA.
IT BLEW UP.
ONE THING ABOUT ASSAD.
NOT A GOOD GUY.
INDIA
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE'RE SPENDING MONEY BACKING
REBELS WHERE WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THEY ARE.
I HAPPEN TO THINK THEY'RE ISIS.
WHO KNOWS.
WE'RE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO GET ASSAD OUT WITH
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THEY ARE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S SMART.
WE HAVE TO REBUILD OUR COUNTRY.
OUR COUNTRY IS FALLING TO
PIECES.
WE HAVE $19 TRILLION IN DEBT.
WE HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
DIS
DISASTER.
OUR ROADWAYS, AIRPORTS, SCHOOLS.
EVERYTHING.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT